well universities effect growth through
a number of channels perhaps most
obviously is the channel of producing
graduates who are skilled people or
human capital and human capital is very
important for growth that's been
established in the economics literature
the other key channel is through
innovation universities through the
graduates that they produce who then go
on to be scientists and produce
innovations universities are a location
for research as well
housing labs where scientists work on
research often in collaboration with
local businesses so these are the two
kind of key map venues through which we
might think that universities affect
growth but there's actually some other
avenues as well and can you put a figure
on the total contribution to UK GDP of
Britain's universities is impossible to
do that
well universities UK have estimated that
it might be just under 3% GDP but they
carry out quite a direct accounting
exercise kind of looking at the
expenditure of universities local
multiplier effects a wider analysis
would include also the effects through
kind of the skilled people going out
into the workforce The Associated spill
overs from skilled people in local areas
there's a large economic literature
based on the u.s. that's proved that
there are these spillover effects and
it's related to agglomeration economies
and similarly with innovation so that's
definitely a lower bound and how do
britain's universities compare with
other countries in terms of the value
that they add well British universities
are you know they're world leading in
most of the international league tables
so for example The Times Higher
Education Rankings there were about five
UK universities in the top 20 worldwide
arts and humanities universities I think
five in the top 21 social sciences and
obviously some top universities in all
different disciplines there's obviously
a big debate going on about the UK's
lousy productivity records a
universities contributing to that by
churning out lots of graduates with
fairly worthless degrees well I mean the
the UK's productivity record is
got a lot worse since the financial
crisis and I wouldn't say that
universities have kind of changed since
then so we have a long-running gap with
our main comparators it's now about 30
percentage points with Germany France
and America but the gap has got wider
since financial crisis so it's unlikely
you know that the universities are
contributing to that I would argue the
opposite that universities have actually
accounted for a lot of the productivity
growth we've seen and particularly it's
kind of since the 1960's that's the
period we've seen a widespread kind of
increase in both the number universities
and the enrollments at universities
there's a lot of evidence you know that
graduates in Kittanning continue to earn
more which means they're valued more in
the labor market and therefore more
productive skills of fundamental really
to productivity the ability to generate
innovations like I said management
practices you know managerial skills
workforce skills are very important for
management practices which are another
driver of productivity sure but as you
say our productivity record has slipped
behind the likes of Germany Germany
sends far fewer of its young people to
university and for more than we do on
apprenticeships and and technical
courses yes so I I think there is a kind
of a well-known gap here in terms of our
technical skills so there's more that
further education colleges can do and
also when we're thinking about the value
of degrees there is quite a lot of
difference between different courses and
different institutions so there's some
recent analysis from the IFS that looks
at big data to try and track the
outcomes of people from different
courses in different universities so you
know there there are probably some cases
where certain individuals a very
well-designed technical education or
vocational education course could better
serve them